نكون قاعدين في الخيم خايفين من القصف
وصوت طيران زنانات وزي هيك فجا بلاقي جمعه
قعد وبدا يغني وكل الناس تتجمع حواليه
كبار والصغار وبيعمل لنا مدحات وكل مخيم
بتجمع عليه وكلنا بنبسط ويعني بيعملنا
سهرات كل خميس كل جمعه بايام محدده
العص يا ح وحيب سلم
عصري القرع
العربي بس هنا في المخيم نا تقريبا 87 يوم
85 يوم والاجواء كانت الناس كلها
كئيبه كابته فقلت له يا باشراك عملنا مدي
خ شويه هيك النفس تريح الاجواء تتغير
والله
بدينا الجميع يعني الجيران الكل
صنت
للمديح الكل اج وقعد يتفاعل معنا الله يا
ساداتي لا
تبعدوا الله الله عني
فاني
ابنكم الله الله جمعه قلج 20 سنه انا فنان
احنا كنا عاملين في الخيمه جلسه على قد
العائله فقط فجاه الناس صارت تجي عندي على
الخيمه تطلب مني اني اعملهم برا بسبب انه
في ناس صارت معها اصابات اجواء الحربا
نغير النفس شوي يعني ل غزتنا
للسما غزتنا للسما رفعناه هال
العتاب هل يا ويله اللي ما يحسب لها
حساب يك فلسطين يا امي ويا روحي فلسطين
بكفيك
جروحي انت في الخيمه فجاه لقيت مره جايه
عم تحكي انه ما كانت تخلف ف رزقت
بطفل فا احتفال في الاحتفال بالطفل انه
لازم اجي اعمل لهم مديح اعملهم حفله انه
لازم يكون عشان نبسط احتفلنا بالطفل
فاجينا وغيرنا جو وعملنا جو للعائله وكانت
هذه مخصصه لاهل البنت وخص كبار السنب اسمك
يا
بلي
عشمس ي ولا
وي من غزه محاصر حاليا ه ما بقدر اني اوصل
رسالتي لازم اطلع برا عشان اشوف حياتي
اشوف مستقبلي وابني مستقبلي بره اما في
غزه صعب في ظل الحصار والحرب على غزه اشكي
لمين وقدي وحالي الله الله ق لي مين النبي
غالي الله الله ايه اللي غير
احوالي غير الغرام برسول
الله